on a une créature un peu bizarre moitié
homme moitié animal ça fait penser à des
créatures que vous avez vues dans dans
certains dessins animés ou d'un certain
film la visite classique d'un château
avec un guide peut être très vite
barbante pour un enfant
les explications historiques étant
rarement adapté à leur niveau de
connaissance alors le château d'amboise
a mis en place une visite spécialement
consacrée aux familles et la guide
catherine reyes un vrai don pour
l'interaction avec les enfants il faut
parler de sujets qui les intéressent en
fait des visites historiques pour les
enfants mais on fait cette visite là qui
a plus ludique et sur le thème des
animaux de la présence des animaux
à l'époque des rois des animaux réels
des animaux imaginaires des animaux
vivants des animaux sculptés représenter
etc et les enfants en plein de choses à
dire aussi sur les animaux un sujet qui
les intéressent
là bas c'est une chouette mais où et
l'escargot à ses plus petits les parents
restent en retrait catherine s'adresse
essentiellement aux enfants qui rentrent
très vite dans son jeu elle est bien
gentil on comprend bien ce qu'elle dit
est faux vraiment fait les chats de l'or
et ce joli c'est intéressant
voilà c'est bien d'avoir pour une fois
une visite vraiment adapté aux enfants
parce que bien souvent voilà au bout du
bout d'un quart d'heure ils s'ennuient
pas ce qu'ils comprennent pas la grande
majorité des explications qui sont
donnés donc voilà c'est très intéressant
baptisé les animaux merveilleux du roi
cette nouvelle visite a lieu tous les
jours à 15h30 jusqu'à la fin du mois